I'm honored to call this man a friend
I've known him for quite some time and I
was a big fan of watching him do his
work he is here as part of rocket
mortgage and their rocket mortgage Super
Bowl squares sweepstakes he is none
other than Pro Football Hall of Famer
Barry Sanders is right here everybody I
am doing fine what do you think of this
game that's coming up this Sunday break
it down for me Barry Sanders but yeah
I'm a awesome matchup
awesome matchup I mean I don't think
there are a lot of people that are
shocked to see these two teams here you
know obviously the Chiefs probably feel
like they could have been here last year
and and even even before Jimmy went down
last last season I mean the Niners were
playing very well so so yeah I mean two
great teams great personalities coaches
great coaching matchup you know you I
you know has an old running back or
former running back I should say once a
running back always right absolutely I
mean I'd like I like what I've seen all
year from the Niners you know they love
running the ball they between those
three running backs there's almost 2000
yards it's amazing how much this pass
first pass heavy spread em wide League
just two years ago you saw a team make
it to the Super Bowl and win it all with
the old rpoS and the run-pass option
with the quarterback who really wasn't
running it as well just winging it all
over the spot and now the Ravens the
49ers the Titans I could go on and on of
teams that have absolutely focused on
the run and and most of the team's top
ten passing teams did not make the
playoffs and learns that all of the
run-heavy teams made the playoffs this
year absolutely they you look at the
runners they were in a playoff like
Derrick Henry or like Dalvin cook even
include even include the quarterback
jaxon in that mix Erik Jones with Erik
Jones back to communities and Frieza
yeah so so the run
back in the running game certainly made
a resurgence this year and so yeah I
love seeing that and and and so and
that's always been historically that was
a great formula for success right great
defense and being able to run the
football and certainly in my era you
know that was pretty much the bottom
line for all those dynasties that won
the big game and so it'll be interesting
just to see you know if that carries
through this year and we hear so much
about the 49ers scheme berry we hear
about how Kyle Shannon creates so many
different runs from so many different
ways that you can't see it's coming from
did you have a scheme or do we just
remember you just doing your own thing
was there a scheme for you I'm happy I
think there was a scheme I don't think
it was as complicated right or maybe run
oriented because if you remember when I
when I first came into the NFL my
offensive coordinator was a guy named
mount's Davis Ronnie Joyce was a running
shoe guy right mount's Davis June Jones
guys like that so my first few years
that's what I did and you know I had I
can't even count the number of offensive
coordinators I had the whole
conversation was let's get Barry a
fullback absolutely that was the whole
conversation at lunch this run and shoot
business let's get Barry a fullback and
let's see what Barry could do
were you desiring a fullback at the time
well I mean that's all I had
that's the only way I ever played the
game and I was I was open to anything
obviously in the running issue we were
we're pretty successful but it's
certainly by no means is a run oriented
offense there was more shoot was that
more shooting a lot of shoot a lot of
shoot absolutely right yep so yes but
but but you know but we had some we had
some intermingled in there toward the
end my career you remember touchdown
tommy Bardell Cory Schlessinger date
those are two guys that I didn't have as
full backs later in my career I love you
brought a smile on over there Chris the
the name of touchdown Tommy right that's
so great what a throwback
that's why we love doing shows like this
we have no idea
we woke up today for a Super Bowl 54
show that we'd be hearing the name
touchdown
Tommy Bartel shout out no doubt about
that
who was the toughest guy for you to Juke
that you knew going in the game I had to
give my special Sanders maneuver that's
hard to say I think I mean I played
against so many great defensive players
one that comes to mind who I played
against early in my career for the
Vikings it was guy named joy browner oh
yeah who a joy was into like karate and
jujitsu and all that kind of stuff music
he was a great safety he was great for
20 years you can say that you know the
safeties and the the big tall guys that
Seattle made famous and recent boys like
Joey we're on or was it that mole
absolutely yeah yeah absolutely
I think he was he was a guy that I felt
like it was kind of hard to trick you
right especially my first couple years I
think eventually I got around to it but
Blake but if I try if I if I just was
gonna pick one but they're so made great
events of players like that played
against you know but but now which is
the greatest defensive player for you
Barry Sanders felt on the wall that you
got that the great the greatest I would
I would probably have to say I mean I I
struggle to say between Lawrence Taylor
in and Reggie White I'll just say Reggie
White because I just know that you know
the way he dominated the defensive and
position yeah when he played and you
know you're in the trenches with with
other giants in the way he dominated
that position in the way that the week
of when he when he played for Green Bay
was when it was when I played him and
when they made the Superbowl run and the
week of practice you would always see
our coaches their offensive coordinators
taking out certain plays in the playbook
saying no we're not gonna run this the
regicide we got a you know obviously
slide to protection a side and doing all
these things making all these
adjustments yes and the game plan for
him and you still couldn't stop him you
know SOI so if I had to pick one player
it had to be the Minister of Defence
Reggie right but did you get him did you
get him at one point where he thought he
had you and you just you got him always
you stay for
away from Reggie you know always just
stayed away from okay to monitor you
just tell me that I don't know I'm sure
at some point I'm sure at some point I
got him and I'm sure at some point he
got me as well what about what about
Lawrence Lawrence oh wow I mean the guy
was just such a beast and in the same
way just so dominant right I'm fortunate
that we didn't play them a lot we
weren't we weren't in the same division
right you know so I'm not I'm not
exactly sure you know how that wasn't
played out but my second game in NFL was
in the Meadowlands against against the
Giants and again like I said we were
running a running shoe and I just
remember him coming up at the end of the
game and just saying to me you know you
guys just scrapped his running shoe you
should get a fullback and you and you
would be unstoppable in this league
that's what he told that's what I
remember about that particular game but
planning its LT well if I remember the
running shoot didn't really have much in
terms of protection and I'm sure it was
oh you didn't have a tight end obviously
they'd leave you to try and chip
Lawrence I know I don't think so I think
they were smarter than that smarter than
that that would be a long day for a
rookie but that's what after that after
the game he said he's yeah he was
basically giving me a compliment saying
hey look man if you got a fullback you'd
be unstoppable you guys just scrapped
his running shoot I don't know if he
ever told our offensive coordinators
that but he certainly told me that I'll
never forget it did you tell your
coaches with Lawrence absolutely a few
more minutes left here with Barry
Sanders who is the running back you
would pay hard-earned Barry Sanders
dollars to see today one guy I want to
see that guy well I mean wow well you
first name that comes to mind obviously
it's Derrick Henry who led the league in
rushing this year and led his team into
the playoffs and a great playoff win and
in New England and it kind of reminds me
of like a Jim Brown type runner right I
mean just big and powerful and fast
you know and just had a dynamic year I
you know I mean you got to give me in
trouble but there's a lot of really good
running backs and I like to watch in
today's game like say Quan Berkeley or
Zeke Elliott or Christian McCaffrey you
I mean the list goes on you know so so
yeah I'm still very much a big fan of
watching that part of the game but but
definitely give the Hat and you know tip
my hat to Derek Henry what he did this
season yeah it's interesting
we were talking before you we came on
the air McCaffrey Stanford guy you're
you sent your kid to play for David Shaw
now Emmett's doing the same thing just
like it's late no it's great a great but
great spot for Hall of Famer running
backs playing you know sons playing at
Stanford it's like David Shaw is
collecting you your your kids one by one
and just bringing him in well you know
he speaks for the kind of job he's done
out there you know and I'm excited for
him it's kid this is a great great
program and just a great atmosphere
that's what I'm trying to say Stanford
you know just a world-class University
and and so you know he will be pleased
out there I'd be remiss if I didn't ask
you about the passing of Chris Dolman
the Minnesota Viking and longtime Viking
in San Francisco 49er as well Hall and
fellow Hall of Famer do you have any
memories of Chris or anything of that
absolutely I mean as I mentioned Joey
browner earlier Chris Dolman would have
been his teammate and Chris was just a
fantastic player just a sharp guy when
you when you met him and talk to him off
the field you realized that there's so
much to him um I saw him last year at
Super Bowl and it I think he had had
rains or cancer surgery and he was on
the mend you know and but just a
all-around great guy and and you know
he's definitely gonna be missed by my
football fans and obviously his
Minnesota Vikings family you know and
just very sad news it is very sad news
and so also
I think he's a hall-of-famer Frank Gore
passed you on the all-time rushing list
here do you think Frank deserves to be
in the Hall of Fame with you one day
Barry I'm assuming so you know again
congratulations to Frank just for the
longevity that he's had you know and the
guys uh you know to still be viable you
know and able to play and put up those
numbers and any any time you're on the
all-time list then you know you had to
work in earn your way on there right and
so again tip of the hat to Frank and and
hey look you know play as long as you
want and play as long as you're having a
good time and is his team had good
success making it to the playoffs and
yeah yes so so good job Frank so tell me
about the rocket mortgage Super Bowl
squares sweepstakes so it's just like
pretty much the the what a lot of folks
do in their own homes which is gaming
square absolutely yeah absolutely uh
we're just trying to put cash in in fans
hands you know like you said the rocket
mortgage Super Bowl square sweepstakes
you every score change a fan is going to
win $50,000 halftime score and the score
at the end of the game about two fans
two lucky fans are going to win half a
million dollars you can go to rocket
mortgage squares calm to sign up it's
free to sign up yeah you know so those
are great reasons there to do it you
really haven't really aren't any good
reasons to avoid this I mean it's just
all-around great game I think fans will
love it most of our favorite team is not
in the game right so and obviously it's
the world's biggest game and and but it
gives you even more of a reason to watch
Super Bowl and be invested in it and
maybe even win a lot of cash so so every
score changed 50,000 the halftime score
and the score in the end of the game
half a million
rocket mortgage squares calm to sign up
a rocket mortgage squares dot-com
um and so when it's all said and done
who's hoisting the Lombardi Trophy got
I'm going to put you on the spot I know
you are known for your elusiveness I'm
just imagine I'm Joey browner right now
and your rookie season without your full
back in the run-and-shoot you've got to
give me a loser a scary man I know it's
Garrett I'm trying I'm trying to I'm
trying to put it on no I mean again it's
it's such a great matchup and I think so
many fans will be invested in it you
know and you've got one of the league's
best offenses against one of the
league's best defenses I'm leaning
what's today is just Wednesday so I'll
pick I'll pick the Niners I'll pick
tonight I'm going with the old formula
for winning Super Bowl who's running the
football and playing great defense you
know and and you know the young head
coach called Shanahan you know hoisting
the Lombardi Trophy that's Barry Sanders
everybody a round of applause for Barry
for more of the Rich Eisen show tune -
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV for free
on BR Live or download the Rich Eisen
show app